in the last presentation i hopefully
gave you a little bit of an intuition of
what a derivative is it's really just a
way to find the slope at a given point
along a curve
now we'll actually apply it to some
functions so let's say i had
i had the function f of x
f of x is equal to
x squared
and i want to know what is the slope
what is the slope of this
curve what is this my pen i need to get
another tool what is the slope
at
not it not it what is the slope at x is
equal to let's say at x equals 3.
what is the slope of x so let's let's
draw out what i'm asking
so that's a coordinate axis that's the
x-coordinate
that's the y-coordinate
and then if i were to draw let me pick a
different color
if this is
so we want to say what is the slope when
x is equal to
3. so
x is equal to say this is x of 3 this is
x equals 3 not x of 3.
and of course when x equals 3
f of x is equal to 9. we know that
right
so what we do is we take a point maybe a
little bit further along the curve let's
say this point right here is 3 plus h
right
and i keep it abstract as h because as
you know we're going to take the limit
as h approaches 0 and at this point
right here
is what it's 3 plus h squared
right because we're just the function is
f of x f of x is equal to x squared so
this point right here is
this point right here is
3 plus h
comma
3 plus h
squared right because we just take 3
plus h and put into x squared and we get
3 plus h squared and this point here is
of course 3 comma 9.
what we want to do is we want to find
the slope between these two points
i really have to find a better tool
this one keeps freezing i think it's too
uh cpu intensive but anyway so we want
to find the slope between these two
points so what's the slope so it's the
change in y so it's 3 plus h squared i'm
going to try 3
plus
h
squared
minus this y minus 9
over
the change in x well that's three plus h
that's
three plus h
right three plus h minus three
minus three
so if we simplify this top part or if we
multiply it out with 3 plus h squared
that's
9
plus
6h
right
plus
h squared and then you get the minus 9
minus 9
and all of that
is over well this 3 and this minus 3
cancel out so all you're left is with h
right and even if we simplify this this
9 minus 9 they cancel out right
9 minus 9.
so let me go
up here
so what we're left is is what we're left
with
6
this pin keeps freezing
it's 6 h
plus h squared
over h
and now we could simplify this right
because we can divide the top and the
bottom the numerator and the denominator
by h and you get you get
6 plus 8 squared
so that's the slope between these two
points right
is 6 plus 8 squared so if we want to
find the instantaneous slope at the
point x equals three
f of x is equal to nine or the point
three nine we just have to find the
limit as h approaches zero here so we'll
just take the limit
as h
approaches zero well this is an easy
limit problem right what's the limit of
six plus h squared as h approaches zero
well it equals six
so we now know that the slope
of this curve at the point x equals
three
is
6.
the slope here is 6.
so if you actually did a you know a
traditional rise over run
this slope this change in y over change
in x is 6. so we have the instantaneous
slope at exactly the point x is equal to
3. so that's useful um we were able to
find the exact you know if this if this
was the graph of uh of someone's um
of someone's position we would then know
kind of the instantaneous velocity right
which is well i won't go into that i'll
do a separate module on physics but this
was useful but let's see if we can do a
more generalized version where we don't
have to know ahead of time what point we
want to find the slope at if we can get
a generalized formula for the
the slope at any point along the graph f
of x is equal to x squared
so let me
clear this
so we're going to stick with
we're going to stick with
oh
my pen
f x
is equal to
x squared
and we know that the slope at any point
of this is just going to be the limit
the
the limit
as h
approaches zero
of f
of x plus h
minus
f of x
all of that
over h
and all this is this this part right
here this is just the slope formula that
you learned years ago it's just change
in y over change in x and all we're
doing is we're we're seeing what happens
as the change in x gets smaller and
smaller and smaller as it actually
approaches zero and that's why we can
get the instantaneous change at that
point in the curve so let's apply this
definition of a derivative to this
function
so and actually
if you want to know the notation i think
this uh this is the notation lagrange
came up with this is equal to
f
prime
of x
don't take my word on it on lagrange you
might want to look it up on on wikipedia
but this is the scenes the derivative of
f of x is f prime of x so let's apply it
to x squared so we're going to say
the limit
as h approaches 0
of f of x plus h well f f of x plus h is
just
x
this pen driving me crazy x
plus
h
squared right i just took the x plus h
and put it into f of x
minus f of x well that's just x squared
over
h
and this is equal to the limit
as h approaches 0 let's just multiply
this out of
x squared
plus
this is 2 x h
2 x h
plus h
squared right plus a squared minus x
squared running out of space
all of that over h
let's simplify this this x squared
cancels out with this minus x squared
right and then we can divide the
numerator and the denominator by h and
we're left with
the limit
as h approaches
0
of let's see
numerator and denominator by h of 2x
plus h
well this is easy this is just equal if
this goes to zero this is just equal to
two x
so there we have it the limit as h
approaches zero is equal to two x so now
we know that and this is equal to f
prime of x so the derivative of f of x
which is denoted by f prime of x
is equal to 2x
well what does this tell us what have we
done for ourselves well now i can give
you any point along the curve
let's say we want to know the slope at
the point
16 right when at the point 16
when
at the point 16 comma 256
right that's a point along f of x equals
x squared right it's just 16 and then 16
squared what's the slope at that point
well we now know the slope is 2 times
16. the slope
at that point if my pen works properly
the slope
is equal to 32. whatever the x value is
you just put it into this f prime of x
function
and or the derivative function and
you'll get the slope at that point i
think that's pretty neat and i'll show
you how in in future presentations how
we can apply this to physics and and
optimization problems and a whole other
set of things and i'm also going to show
you how to find the derivatives for a
whole set of other functions i'll see in
the next presentation